Phil you know where Kurdistan is and you
know where Syria is do we know where
Baghdad is this morning what is the
state of affairs with in the nation's
capital it's in a bad place look at us
officials really are just starting to
wake up a lot of them didn't sleep much
last night and the issue right now tom
is they're involved in such a roller
coaster yesterday was a very positive
day up north the Kurdish forces the
Peshmerga made gains they're pushing
back I think the u.s. feels very
vindicated if there's any question at
all that their air strikes have been
extraordinarily helpful to Kurdish
forces and then the political resolution
which frankly is the most important
thing the president has said it over and
over again US officials have said it
over and over again took a major major
step back there will be no long-term
solution if there is not some type of
resolution in Baghdad and what's going
on with Nuri al-maliki right now right
he's extraordinarily concerning to us
officials do we in any way support mr.
Maliki no and this is the interesting
thing actually Tom over the last 12
hours that I've seen US officials have
always been very careful with their
language I remember we were speaking
probably two months ago and we talked
behind the scenes he was being made very
clear to us that they would like a new
prime minister over the last probably
four or five days even the president in
his remarks announcing the potential
airstrikes last week noted that they
want a quote new prime minister last
night shortly probably 15 minutes after
Nuri al-maliki gave his short statement
on state TV last night brett mcgurk the
top State Department official and Iraq
quickly went on to Twitter and said
plain and simple guys the u.s. supports
fluid minim mazoun sorry the president
they have no support for Nuri al-maliki
in this case they're yeah they're just
going all out now it's not a secret Phil
let me make sure I understand this
correctly in addition to everything
that's going on up north we actually
don't know who's in charge of Iraq right
now it's it's difficult right so the I
think yeah frankly Brendan I've it's
actually true to the one I'm going to
figure a terrifying point on it right
I'm trying to figure out some way to
make this sound logical and there just
isn't I think Nouri al-maliki has lost
the vast majority of supporting all you
need to look at Grand Ayatollah Sistani
the top co-leader the kind of the
main individual that the she is in Iraq
listened to has criticized heavily
politicians who quote cling to power
that's a direct shot at Nuri al-maliki
however Nuri al-maliki has strong
control over special forces in the
country over what you've seen move into
the green zone right now and as long as
that exists it's a very very dangerous
game that's being played right now this
conversation Olivia I think the most
interesting thing is the overlay of the
religion and the different sects of
Islam with where the United States is
right now we're beholdin two centuries
of history here of course now what we're
talking about it seems like only
foreigners want to be redrawing the
lines of the Ottomans in the British
first put down it really is incredible
that we're talking about redrawing the
lines in Iraq but fill a question for
you if you say if President Obama says
there's no American military solution
and what is the solution what's next
over the weekend we heard senators
McCain and Senator Graham going on the
airwaves saying that air strikes in
Syria should be the next part of the
equation its mission creep inevitable
here is Syria next I think the
president's statements about having no
timeline here has certainly spooked
Democrats I think when we spoke on
Friday said the president hasn't gotten
any major blow back from his party that
changed this weekend with those
statements that there is no firm
deadline I will say Olivia every
American official i've talked to who's
involved in this or knows what's going
on says airstrikes in syria are simply
not on the table this is a rock specific
but i do think that you're going to
continue to hear pressure from
Republicans to do more and you're
starting to see Democrats move away from
the President on this until he puts kind
of a firmer guideline in place on how
long this will last and how many strikes
there will be you're going to lose top
people like the Assistant Majority
Leader dick Durbin said this weekend
Phil there's also a whiff of an American
power struggle cocoon to Hillary told
the Atlantic that she would have done
things completely different in Syria so
there's also a new reality within the
Beltway as well this morning yeah
Brendan I think the interesting thing is
we have all been kind of expecting
Hillary Clinton to start breaking away
from the administration at some point
frankly she has to if you just look at
the numbers that President Obama is
bringing to the table right now on
foreign policy it was no secret that she
was more of a hawk on Syria than the
president
was I think that was her point in the
fantastic interview with Jeffrey
Goldberg but I do think that she was so
sharp with her criticism and she brought
up his kind of the statement of the
president keeps bringing the table don't
do stupid stuff as being one of the the
right he forms of his foreign policy
doctrine and she not only repeated that
and then criticized it she took a big
step away from him today and I think
that just doesn't help the scenario that
we're dealing with right now for the
president Phil Mattingly thanks for
making us smarter on a Monday morning he
is in Washington